القنابل العنقوديه تاريخ اسود ذكرياته
قابعه بالذاكره وتداعيته التي تقتل بصمت
وغدر باتت معروفه صحيفه جارديان اكدت ان
اجيالا كثيره قد تعاني من قرار بايدن
بارسال قنابل عنقوديه الى اوكرانيا وذكرت
بمقتل واصابه عشرين الفا من اللاوسيين
نصفهم تقريبا من الاطفال بسبب قنابل غير
منفجره منذ انتهاء حرب فيتنام نصف قرن مر
على قصف الولايات المتحده لاراضي لاوس
والقائها اكثر من مليونيرتون من القنابل
العنقوديه على مساحات شاسعه لكن الامر قد
يستغرق 100 سنه اخرى لتطهير البلاد
بالكامل من تلك القنابل فهذا النوع من
الاسلحه وفق الصحيفه يتجاوز ضرره الحرب
الى اجيال طويله بعدها فطبيعه كارثيه دفعت
حوالي 120 دوله للتوقيع على اتفاقيه حظر
القنابل العنقوديه للمفارقه لائحه
الموقعين على اتفاقيه حاضر استخدام وانتاج
ونقل وتخزين القنابل العنقوديه لم تشمل
الولايات المتحده او حتى طرفي الصراع
المتمثلين بروسيا واوكرانيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات